well this is the second day of carnival
it's a huge celebration across South and
Central America and particularly in the
Caribbean as well the figures we've got
at the moment are varying wildly from
the reports we're getting somewhere
between 10 and 20 people more like 15 16
17 18 as you were saying but many many
people injured it happened at about 2 45
this morning local time it was still
dark and we had the streets absolutely
packed with tens of thousands of
partygoers and going through all of
these worthy floats the floats pulled by
lorries with people on top of them sound
systems and in the last couple of
minutes i've seen some video which
appears to show the singer and one on
the top of one of these floats inching
towards a power cable but because he was
looking to the to the side unaware that
he was about to actually make contact
with it with his head huge flash lots of
people screaming and it seems that
people have either been electrocuted and
some also possibly have died in a panic
which followed it sounds appalling and
just you can you get the sum of the
sense of the chaotic scenes there from
the pictures that we're seeing now
terrible incident these affairs tend to
be be sometimes disorganized sometimes
pretty chaotic certainly very
unregulated and you're talking about a
country like Haiti clearly the
infrastructure there is not going to be
the safest certainly not safe as you
expect in North America or in Europe so
the fact that these kinds of things
occasionally happen it is not entirely
surprising but we're talking about 15-20
people dead here that's certainly out of
the ordinary and clearly it's a tragedy
for the people of this small island
President Martelly expressing his
sincerest sympathies as regards the
singer who was electrocuted it appears
that he is in a critical condition in
hospital but he at the moment is still
alive